et regardez il est là pour faire la
gauche tape dessus c'est le haut dans
magic violon le honor magic v je vous en
avais déjà parlé vous regarder je vous
l'avait présenté en vidéo il ya pas
longtemps mais il a pu venir ici et il a
pu venir parce que normalement le honor
magic vrai qu'il y en a en france il est
là et il peut pas venir ils doivent
venir avec son garde du corps qui est
leur est aléatoire approche toi c'est
georges c'est georges leone ans à
majorque c'est très bien ouais mon
record et ben écoute ravi de t'avoir
avec moi lors du coup ben voila j'ai dit
il à son garde du corps veillait tout
quitterait surveille de très très près
donc l'idée aujourd'hui c'est pas de
serre au test de smartphones clairement
non parce qu'on ne pourrait pas à déjà
pourquoi parce que il n'ya pas les
services google actions qui sont dedans
c'est un produit qui vient directement
de chine il a été épuré ils ont enlevé
des applications chinoise pour autant on
a pas tous beaucoup on va regarder et
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir de
quelle manière au nord est venu
travailler ici pour monter en gamme très
clairement et en levant depuis que au
nom n'est plus avec war où ils ont fait
un vrai travail pour avoir une gamme
complète de l'entrée du milieu de gamme
du haut de gamme jusqu'aux très haut de
gamme jusqu'à de l'innovation de la
smart phones qui speed donc on a rien
aujourd'hui à quoi ressemble ce honneur
magic v on va le mettre en face d'autres
concurrents un peu dans cet esprit ray
puis on va regarder si au final au nord
a bien bossé ou alors peut-être
absolument pas
allez on y va on ouvre la boîte à la
tendance où vais je suis pas lâché sa
boîte moi j'ai racheté boîte us on
arrive directement dessus alors on se
fait un petit one boxing rapide il ya
déjà été ouverts fois que c'est qui
c'est josiane qu'il a déjà vu ce qu'il a
donc il a déjà fait une vidéo dessus
donc à temps par là donc ça c'est ça
alors à la tarière regarder ça c'est
marrant alors je voulais dire c'est pas
un produit français donc on n'a pas de
blog de charge français ça c'est de la
super de charges au nord ces deux-là 66
what et alors y'a un truc qui est très
marrante c'est qu'ils sont hyper chaud
sur les blocs de charge 60 6 watts
allume-cigare donc si dans votre voiture
vous avez une prise allume cigare goût
et de la recharge rapide pas regardé
vous avez ici on sera six ans perd 11 et
12,5 ball 2 ans perd la radio m la plus
tôt là vous avez durant ce vol six ans
père et du cinq vols deux ans banon
pourquoi pas plutôt rigolo qu'est ce
qu'on a ici plus rien selon du bull ont
dû s'envoler petit protection aux pieds
de quoi ouvrir le tiroir de cartes sim
pour envoyer le packaging est plutôt
sympa plutôt bien fait quand je vous dis
que c'est un produit qui vient de chine
je ne vous mens pas regardez c'est écrit
en chinois et puis voilà alors attendez
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ça cette
petite bête alors à plat il déjà allumé
les magnifiques pas le progrès alors on
connaît le form factor on a déjà vu ce
form factor la différence qu'on va voir
ici c'est la technologie goutte d'eau
alors c'est quoi l'idée de la
technologie goutte d'eau l'idée de la
technologie goutte d'eau c'est lorsque
vous allez venir le plier comme ça en
fait regardez vous voyez là l'idée c'est
que votre écran n'est pas une pliure au
centre qu'ils soient pas coupés plier au
milieu l'idée c'est que ça devienne
l'accompagner pour justement ne pas
avoir sensation de pliure sous le doigt
alors on sent quelque chose on va pas se
mentir il ya des conflits je le sens
d'autant plus que la la je pense que
vous allez bien le voir essayer de dire
nous sommes un petit peu à plat la ici
je sens que mon écran et plein là je
sens qu'il ya toute une petite partie
charnière dont il ya un petit
renfoncement légèrement ici là je
récupère l'écran ici donc ça dans le
sang mais on va pas voir comme sur un z
fold voyez la pliure plutôt centrale est
plutôt prononcé plus tôt plutôt très
affirmée donc il ya vraiment un truc qui
est très très différents c'est beaucoup
plus doux en fait sous le doigt alors
j'imagine que ça me semble bien
également bossé pour diminuer cette
sensation parce que ils voient bien ce
que font les autres et que bouddha m'en
faut vous venir corriger ce petit truc
là donc il ya une vraie différence là
dessus et c'est justement l'idée lorsque
vous allez venir le plier alors je passe
en avant sa rencontre garder c'est que
voyez s'appuie pas en sons sont
directement donc ça vient pas plié ça
vient papa c'est l'écran en fait donc ça
c'est assez rigolo donc très gros boulot
qui était fait aussi au niveau de la
charnière alors il ya un truc qui est
intéressant c'est que si vous voulez
travailler pour muscler votre main vous
avez un vrai un vrai retour là en fait
oui je le sens large et plus tout à fait
comme ça là où un patent j'avais plus a
besoin de sentir un petit comme si
comment pourrais dire si c'est vrai
c'est une résistance je sens une espèce
de petite résistance elle veut pas se
refermer celle là alors elle veut pas
mais une fois qu'on l'a mise là ta
classe est fermée c'est bien fermé donc
là ça va alors le truc qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que regarder au niveau
conception ils ont vraiment bossé que
même qu'on ait le côté goutte d'eau on
n'a pas le côté pince et là par contre
c'est vraiment fermé alors et si on
vient regarder par rapport à samsung eux
ils ont pas la goutte d'eau et c'est
papin c'est donc c'est des petites
différences de conception qui sont assez
rigolote et de voir ce que ça vient
donner au final alors petit aparté ils
nous ont mis un petit capteur de petit
émetteur pour de l'infrarouge ici haut
parleurs là haut parleurs là ce qui vous
permet d'avoir lorsque vous l'ouvrez
complètement et vous voulez écouter un
peu de musique ou jouer un jeu regarder
un film une série est bien vos
haut-parleurs alors attention faut pas
déconner parce que si vous dites je les
mets dans ce sens là bloqué haut
parleurs et ça marche par son malin
quand même chose donc c'est assez c'est
assez rigolo grand écran intérieur alors
je vous l'avais déjà dit j'ai noté
respecte ici à l'écran il fait quoi
c'est dû 7,9 tous à l'intérieur ça
informant un peu particulier sur un
format 10 9e et vous avez un grand écran
extérieur de 6 45 pouces qui est quand
même très très grand aussi pour le coup
et qui vient occuper une grande partie
est bien de la surface avant avec le
petit point sont là taux de
rafraîchissement 120 air 90 à ses
intérieurs dont ils ont vraiment bien
bossé je trouve au niveau de toute cette
partie alors on va pas garder la partie
software qui serait pourtant intéressant
parce que eh bien on n'est pas sur une
version française et européenne pour
autant regarder on va s'ouvrir quoi on
va s'ouvrir un firefox par exemple nous
ont fait un petit truc pour le
multitâche on peut le faire sauf
ailleurs quand tout sera ok
mais sur une note aux cas voilà je la
vois regardez-la en eau la jespo titre
est là et alors ce petit trailer il est
marrant c'est à dire que je peux choisir
où est ce que je mets en fait ma part
mon panneau de notes soit à gauche comme
ça donc après effectivement c'est dire
moduler mettre un petit peu comme je
veux et là je peut m'ouvrir quoi par
exemple un email aux mouvements un email
bon ok c'est pas configuré histoire donc
là je me mets comme je veux et alors
après il ya un autre truc qui me
disaient de picture in picture je ne
récupère jamais ou à aller là ok j'ai
compris il est là il a un peu caché au
kg là et l'aja puis là là sur cette
partie là et la gelée en picture in
picture ce qui me permet d'avoir ma
fenêtre que je peux mettre un peu je
veux je peux la redimensionner ou pas ça
s'appelle léger bonaldi succès a connaît
cette histoire de fées bonaldi ainsi si
on peut là ok ça marche j'ai compris ça
c'est marrant au niveau software à ce
qui était fait les chiens donc ça ça
fonctionne ariano truc qui est assez
marrant regarder la jumenterie ouvriers
l'application pour passer un coup de fil
mardi ou quoi ou hop là vous seriez pas
un peu et vous pouvez venir à avoir des
contacts rapide alors la gelée là il
faut que j'ai un petit trait un
enquêteur va se chercher une application
avec un petit trait galerie chez sony
avec agrafe autre chose qu'aux vers le
haut comme ça voilà donc là il n'y a
rien donc ok fichiers vers le haut j'ai
donc des fichiers mais qui n'est pas
donc voilà on peut bien intégré au site
restait que ça va rester là ok assaf un
petit widget donc ça sera donc après je
peux supprimé mon widgets de la même
manière et se faire retirer ok gelé avec
le bloc notes donc ça c'est tout tout
con baisser les petits trucs software
qui sont assez malins qui vont apporter
en termes d'expérience utilisateur donc
je trouve ça assez rigolo à vous le
voyez une fois plus là je voulais dit on
est vraiment sur un côté avec les apps
chinoise donc il ya des choses qu'on ne
retrouvera pas nous sur nos smartphones
en france art attendait un smartphone il
n'est pas arrivé en france il n'arrivera
pas en france on verra ce qui arrivera
parce que j'imagine que l'histoire va
continuer du côté de scie au nord avec
du pia parce que si on nous montre sa
aujourd'hui sortie en chine ça prouve
qu'il ya d'autres produits qui vont
arriver que le pliage va continuer à
arriver comme on le voit avec d'autres
marques alors aujourd'hui le marché
grand public au niveau du club l'état
particulièrement florissant parce que
c'est l'épaule écoute même très très
cher on est quoi l atelier de 1300 à
1400 euros si on avait un équivalent
donc c'est pas rien alors encore
honnêtement 1300 à 1400 euros c'est
toujours mieux que mille 900 euros 2000
euros pour un smartphone qui se plie ça
va arriver parce que ce smartphone là
malgré tout il est quand même assez
épais il est à garder si je viens le
mettre dans une poche n'obtenant celle
là il prend un peu de place il est un
peu épais donc fatalement on va pas
forcément tout de suite revenir dessus
il faut que les gens le voient il faut
que les gens se rendent compte de
l'intérêt du pliable et des usages et
surtout il fait 280 g donc ça reste
quand même assez lourds c'est pas le
smartphone le plus léger du monde mais
une fois de plus on a deux écrans on va
avoir deux batteries à l'intérieur on va
avoir une batterie pour l'écran
intérieur on va aussi avoir une batterie
pour l'écran extérieur donc forcément on
va rajouter du poil à sucre donc ça ça
me paraît assez normal de la performance
d'el évidemment alors ils sont pas dus
on va sortir un smartphone comme ça puis
on va faire un truc là et maintenant
elle nous emmène à stan dragon's 8
jonone première génération ça me paraît
aussi logique partie photo alors bon on
va pas s'attarder trop sur la partie
photo parce qu'on va pas aller le tester
mais c'est pareil rendez vous avez un
triptyque ici ça va être quoi grand
temps ultra longtemps et on a grand
angle ultra grand temps on a le spectrum
nm ce cadre là ok et puis on va avoir un
capteur tough laser pour votre mode
portrait donc bon ok qui est planqué
juste là et puis caméras extérieures ici
est également caméras à l'intérieur vous
avez là ça ça me paraît normal c'est un
peu l'idée de ce que faisait également
samsung avec son galaxy z paul ii l'a
donc ça me paraît très très logique est
ce que je vous ai pas me regarder on va
regarder la pl petite caméra ou est ce
qu'ils leur femme ce que ça m'amène
dessus ça me mène dessus directement
donc y'a un côté software aussi voyez
qui est vraiment aboutie avec un
tracking du visage assez marrant aussi
un petit suivi du visage et une petite
reconnaissance donc vous voyez non il ya
un choix de boulot on va qui est un beau
boulot software qui a été fait ici pour
apporter l'expérience complète et
globale au niveau du pliable et des
petites choses qui sont assez marrante
avec ce petit côté voyez là pour avoir
ces petits raccourcis petit widget donc
voilà j'aime bien l'idée je trouve
intéressante alors je reste un peu sur
ma faim parce que c'est un smartphone
j'aurais envie de tester j'ai envie de
l'avoir avec moi j'ai envie de prendre
du temps pour tout vous raconter voir ce
qu'on peut faire mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd hui c'est
vraiment une découverte l'idée kulesha
pas ce que vous en pensez vous que ce
que qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
smartphone est ce que vous pourriez déjà
être tenté par un smartphone qui se plie
quel que soit le format attention là
c'est vraiment l'idée du format où on
vient agrandir pour avoir un très grand
écran donc ça est ce que ça pourrait
vous arriver ou est ce qu a contrario
vous seriez plus comme les galaxy z
flics voyous ont rétréci un peu le
format qu'est ce que vous pensez de sae
est ce que vous at on eu ce que vous
pourriez être intéressé ce que vous êtes
en auriez dû vous êtes chez le ch et
honore un smartphone pliable est ce que
c'est cette marque là que vous iriez
acheter un smartphone pliable ça c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant ça il va
regarder les commentaires je sais qu'il
a gardé les commentaires mais c'est
vachement intéressant parce que quand on
regarde d'où vient au nord il ya
quelques années vous savez il était avec
huawei c'était la même histoire je ne
suis plus tout la même histoire tout est
séparé donc c'est vraiment vraiment
différent et au début c'était la marque
jeune de huawei donc quand on a acheté
un smartphone d onna on a acheté un
smartphone d'entrée milieu de gamme
plutôt à destination d'un public plus
jeune et aujourd'hui on voit que
l'histoire serait écrit ils sont séparés
et forcément ils vont pas rester dans un
segment entrée milieu de gamme 100 fois
c'est compliqué son profil très
rapidement manger par la concurrence
parce que le marché tellement
concurrentiel donc ça veut dire que tu
as au besoin d'une gamme complète donc
ça veut dire entre et milieu de gamme on
tire un peu on va sur le haut de gamme
et il faut montrer également
l'innovation comme ça donc voilà est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous plus ou moins
convaincu par ce que vous propose au
nord on a vu dans cinq ans pour
l'attester dernière on a regardé déjà le
jour au mwc le honor magic quatre pros
que je trouvais assez intéressant aux
requins on testera plus tard quand il
arrivera et est ce que l'innovation
comme ça avec la smart client pliable
vous pourriez aller chez honneur est ce
que vous feriez confiance au nord c'est
intéressant on regardera ça voilà donc
on reparlera très bientôt de honor merci
georges de m'avoir emmené ce produit
plutôt cool parce qu'il ya pas vraiment
qu'il l'ait vu utile de ces chouettes on
reparlera de sa bientôt prenez soin de
vous je vous embrasse et puis vous avez
des questions suggestions interrogations
que ce soit sur au nord ou sur autre
chose aurait pu parler de la vie par les
amours voulu marquer en bas en
commentaire prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt chaos
[Musique]